hey youtubers it's Charlie so Warner
Brothers and DC are totally doing the
thing they're making a Booster Gold Blue
Beetle movie they did announce a date
but they did confirm that Greg Berlanti
was going to be directing that's the
only person that they've announced they
haven't announced who's writing it yet
most do you probably know who Greg
Berlanti is you know he's got behind the
flash arrow pretty much most of the DC
TV universe with a few exceptions if
you're not a comic book reader and
you're confused as to why everyone's
freaking out about this I mean obviously
it's a new DC movie it's gonna be canon
with the Batman V Superman universe so
that I mean that's a big deal but
Booster Gold and Blue Beetle are like
the best buddy cop team in the comic
book universe for DC then like DC's Bert
and Ernie and a whole lot more than that
if you go to some of the darker places
on tumblr just just beware when you
search for stuff there's some really
questionable fan art out there oh wait
no this was actually in a comic book
this is actually something that they did
for real but you get the idea
Booster Gold Blue Beetle awesome comedy
movie in the making and everybody kind
of understands what was going on
whenever Andrew Kreisberg from the flash
said that DC and Warner Brothers would
let them use Ted Kord for arrow they
actually they wanted Brandon rouse Adam
character to be the Ted Kord Blue Beetle
they'd been teasing him since season 1
so they're gonna be like okay finally
here he is Ted Kord BAM but they said
when they were pitching arrow season 3
to the network they were like oops sorry
we have other plans for that character
turns out they wanted to use him for a
movie the only other really big rumor
I've heard about it is that the writer
that they're looking at might be Zack
Penn and he's had a long history with
the x-men franchise as well as a partial
treatment on Avengers one of the
transformer movies and the ready player
one movie that Steven Spielberg is
directing he gets a lot of criticism but
I do have a lot of faith in the Berlanti
people they do TV really really well and
I think as long as Warner Brothers
doesn't mess with the film too much it
should be pretty awesome it's it's gonna
be one of those mid budget films between
big Batman V Superman films it's the
exact same thing that Star Wars doing
with their film universe you know you
have like that episode seven eight-nine
between those you have the spin-off
films what about actors okay so
everybody's wondering who's he gonna
cast for this film well typically they
tend to cast younger I know everybody is
like hey Nathan Fillion said he wanted
to play a Booster Gold I don't think
that's gonna happen now he does do a ton
of stuff with Warner Brothers animation
and he appeared as a creature in
guardians of the
see so I totally think that Nathan
feeling can be involved with a film I
just don't think that he's gonna be one
of the lead stars they want like 20
something's not 40 something's think 21
Jump Street which is actually funny
because Lord and Miller are actually
writing the flash movie I know a lot of
people are wondering about that too I
haven't done a lot of flash movie videos
just because there's really nothing
going on with it right now I thought one
of you guys asked me this morning if
they had actually bailed on the flash
movie because they'd signed onto the Han
Solo movie I couldn't find any evidence
to support that online so and until we
get more information I'm just assuming
they're doing both the flash and Han
Solo what I think is happening is that
they're just writing the flash movie and
they're directing the Han Solo movie
like they're not directing the flash
movie that would probably make it hard
for them to do both films that they were
writing and directing both films but
that's not the case the job of the
director and the producers is typically
the most demanding so like if you're a
producer under director on a film you're
gonna be living with it for about four
years but if you're just a writer then
you might only be working on a film for
a fraction of that
so everybody freaked out about how
awesome this is I'm just so excited the
potential for a Booster Gold Blue Beetle
movie I know a lot of you are wondering
you know like what's the deal because
they didn't announce this movie whenever
they announced their big film slate so
if you remember earlier this year Marvel
did their big phase 3 announcement where
they're like here are all the movies
that we're going to be doing for the
next billion years and then a couple
weeks later Warner Brothers is like hey
look we have 10 DC films - the thing is
though is that some of those movie
titles have changed like originally
there was a Green Lantern flash
crossover movie not happening now
there's gonna be a Green Lantern's movie
is in like Green Lantern Corps and then
there's gonna be a flash movies
separately they also had not originally
planned for a new Batman standalone
trilogy Ben Affleck had just been signed
to play Batman and the Justice League
team-up movies it's a little bit more
complicated than that obviously you know
part of the reason I think that Ben
Affleck signed on was because DC and
Warner Brothers was like hey we'll let
you write and direct some of these
Batman films so I think part of what
attracted him to the DC Universe was the
idea that he'd be able to do that
speaking of which Batman standalone
trilogy don't forget Geoff Johns is
actually co-writing the first film
really what I'd like to see is Geoff
Johns get like sole credit on writing a
comic book film I think he's long
overdue he's one of the best writers
that DC has if you guys had
been reading darkside war you need to
check it out even though he hasn't
gotten a whole lot of credit for a lot
of like the big DC movies that have come
out the past couple years I think of him
is like a shadow writer like the guy who
sits in the room and helps them create
these film characters just to get you
guys ready though here's a couple
recommends for Booster Gold Blue Beetle
stories from the comics starting with
time masters vanishing point very
important Ford legends of tomorrow - so
this is this involves rip hunter Booster
Gold Blue Beetle trying to go back in
time and find Batman after Final Crisis
probably one of the best ones in recent
memory is Booster Gold futures in number
one he became this really big character
as DC started to reboot its universe
another really cool story that involves
the time masters and then if you're
looking for like the sillier Booster
Gold Blue Beetle relationship you could
do 50 to pick up blue and gold that's a
bit more of a deep cut but it does a
really good job of showing off some of
the different portrayals of Booster Gold
most of the time when you think about em
you think of this loveable douchebag
character but during the blue and gold
run they tease the idea that Booster
Gold only acts like a douchebag to throw
his enemies off so that they
underestimate him so what a coincidence
that I spent all that time talking about
the time masters Doctor Who series 9
premieres tomorrow
it's a Saturday night show it airs on
the BBC and BBC America depending on
where you live if you're not familiar
with it I've already done a couple guide
so I'll put links in the description but
they just announced that clora the
current companion is leaving at the end
of the year Jenna Coleman is leaving
Doctor Who so I'm trying to start the
hype train so that Maisie Williams will
sign on to be the new companion for
series 10 so please help me roll the
hype train I'll totally do a video later
today just explaining what's going on
with that well you guys wait for all
that stuff to drop though you can click
here for all the latest arrow and flash
trailers that's coming in a couple weeks
and you can click here to learn about
what's going on with Batman V Superman
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight